[Music]
dude that was so good you're spoiling me
with these homemade curry meals
I guess I'm already homesick man you
insisted on cooking so I'll do the
dishes are you gonna use the dishwasher
microwave not gonna wash him but your
hands do why would he use my lovely
hands we have a machine that can do the
dirty work because he just sprays water
into plates you gotta have the hand
motion look we only have a couple of
plates it's a terrible waste of water
okay I get that but like that's like
buying a brand-new car and then not
driving it because gas is too expensive
or run up the mileage not bad but you're
not gonna win this oh my god logic
always wins then I'll defeat you with
science all right bring it on hey
washing sponge that is a breeding ground
for bacteria
how ironic on your quest for cleanliness
and hygiene that you invite more germs
into your home that's exactly why I
microwave the squash
[Music]
okay this dishwasher produces scalding
hot water water that your puny soft
hands could never handle one should
always Jimmy up before an important
mission you end up using more water when
hand wash more hot water means more
energy is consumed which means more
resources are needed to make that energy
then we have to dig up more coal and
natural gases and create giant power
plants that explode sometimes then BAM
no more sushi for anyone I give in to
your no-shoe policy let me have this one
let this wonderful machine do what it
was created to do don't just you don't
let it sit there and shame not allowed
to do with sole purpose banished to a
life as a common dish rack alright
alright go ahead push the buttons really
let's see it
[Music]
I get the sense that this is still
bothering you your point wasn't a
slam-dunk I'm gonna need a Vince Carter
to be satisfied you know what they say
see a rainbow you got a weather the
storm
I see this is a sad attempt they're
trying to get me to realize something
are you trying to make out you need to
be the plate to understand this is my
friend Vince Carter
I don't want to be a plate just notice
how the machine is doing all that dirty
work for us while it cleans my car we
can just sit back and chill the way God
intended things to be okay let's say
your car's of plates and we're in a
dishwasher
would you eat off of this car I know how
you love baby bump you gotta just kind
of dance with it you know what you like
it spicy right do it's whatever we do it
your way
sesame oil I'm point ma'am Wow
this is so good you win this round but
no reason to waste any good food it's my
favorite food I didn't come around II
[Music]